great thing about the Internet is it
disintermediate the message you know
people will now go to the website make
up their own minds they don't need a
professional leftist TV journalist
standing in front of the camera with a
microphone telling them what they ought
to think about something hi I'm Michael
Moynihan for recent TV and I'm here
today with M Hannon of southeast England
and Internet superstar yeah I think
you're a superstar at this point 2.5
million views of your great denunciation
of Gordon Brown in European Parliament
tell us a little bit was this a total
shock to you but out of nowhere you can
give us a general idea of what your
denunciation of Gordon Brown was well I
tried to say to him what I figured my
constituents would want to say to him if
they were there which is that he's
spending all their money and there's
nothing to show for it I was completely
flabbergasted by the way it took off I
still don't really understand why it may
have been that it was a three-minute
speech which is a kind of good YouTube
length it's about the average length of
a pop video maybe I don't know it may
simply have been that it was a surrogate
way of giving the guy a bit of a
slapping for all the people would have
liked to have done it themselves the
amazing thing is it shows that nobody
can predict what the public is going to
like great thing about the Internet is
it disintermediate the message you know
people will now go to the website make
up their own minds they don't need a
professional leftist TV journalist
standing in front of the camera with a
microphone telling them what they ought
to think about something this stuff
resonates obviously with the American
right and the American libertarian right
who are your political influences I've
seen you reference Ron Paul I believe
your breath reference Hayek and Friedman
on your blog I tell us a little about
all of those guys right always take the
rest as read you know in Ain Rand and
the area and in a British context Enoch
Powell you know he was as a somebody who
understood the importance of national
democracy who understood why you needed
to live in an independent country and
what that meant as well as being a free
market here in a small government
conservative but going a bit further
back some of the Patriot leaders who
founded the US on British political
principles although those principles of
subsequently lost in Britain but the
you know the The Jeffersons and the
atoms and the Washington's
the idea of a executive constrained by a
legislature of laws only being passed
with popular consent of taxes not being
raised except by elected legislators
those those were the ideals that have
done most to keep mankind prosperous and
happy and free you have a book called
the plan and it is a plan for what and
what is what are the sort of main sort
of tenants of the plan one way of
putting it is that it is an application
of Jeffersonian principles to UK
political conditions so we are pushing
for the ideal that decisions should be
taken as closely as possible to the
people that they affect decision makers
should be accountable through the ballot
box and the citizen should be as free as
possible from state coercion that sounds
very easy very banal when you translate
it into policy in a British context it
becomes incredibly radical it means we
would have elected sheriffs local sales
tax dispersal of power self financing
local authorities referendums and
initiative procedures shifting power
from the government to Parliament a lot
of things which you would take for
granted in North America and you know
which are often in a British context
attacked as my attempt to Americanized
Britain you know your own you're copying
all these things that states rights and
the sheriffs and so on
to which my answer is where did they get
those ideas from the Patriot leaders of
the 18th century you know they didn't
see themselves as radicals at the time
they saw themselves as conservatives in
their own minds when they took up arms
they were fighting to defend what they
had always assumed to be their
birthright as Freeborn British subjects
and the the innovators as they saw it
were those in the Hanoverian court who
were trying to suck power away from
Parliament's and into the executive so
we're in this strange situation where we
exported the tradition of British
freedom to this part of the world where
it thrived but in the mother country its
withered and so I I desperately want us
to bring back to repatriate our
revolution and bring back the principles
that have served to keep this country
free back to the place where they
originated
so currently you're trying to bring and
again again this is your critic saying
Americanization which is obviously a
dirty word in more of an American
direction where we have a government
that is desperately trying to bring us
more in a european direction so I
suspect the question that you're getting
quite a bit these days or questions
about the NHS what has your experience
been with the British system what would
you warn people away from this would you
tell them to embrace it what's your
what's your general take I would warn
people away because when you see a
friend about to make a mistake you tell
him you know you know you don't let him
walk into making the same mistake that
you made look this isn't just my opinion
you could you will always have anecdotal
stories about people having a wonderful
experience or a terrible experience what
you need to do is is try and be as
empirical as you can about this look at
the actual data you know would you
rather be ill in the u.s. system or in
the UK system and the answer if you look
at survival rates for cancer or stroke
or heart disease that is unquestionably
that you would be better off in the US
the that's that's just fact now some of
people watching this may have seen that
extraordinary film where Michael Moore
kind of goes waddling around saying ah
but you know mortality is better in the
UK life expectancy is long that's
probably true overall right life
expectancy is longer in the UK because
we have less teenage crime and this kind
of but the relevant question in terms of
health care is what is your life
expectancy from the moment that you are
diagnosed with out of these conditions
and the answer is it is far worse in the
UK than in not only than in the US but
then in other countries that have a kind
of mixed system for the most obvious
reason which is that the government runs
things badly it is no more competent at
running hospitals and it was at building
cars or operating airlines or installing
telephones the state is not a good
manager and this is something you guys
have dealt with for many years I mean I
always reference back to a reference the
yes minister episode where there is a
opening a hospital and they said we
don't need any patients we need a
hospital you would place to employ
people we don't actually have to treat
any what beers yeah and it's the perfect
Hospital because it's clean nobody dies
there because there are no patients you
know like so many things in that Yes
Minister series it was eerily prophetic
the NHS now employs 1.4 million staff of
whom a majority are administrators
the bureaucrats the managers outnumber
the doctors and nurses within that 1.4
million and that's what makes it such a
difficult system to get rid of because
you then have this huge block of people
who have a vested interest in the status
quo and that's why I would say to
Americans watching this think hard
before you start down this road don't
imagine that you can experimentally
bring in a government option and then if
it doesn't work out you can just reverse
it that isn't our experience it will
grow and grow it will start sucking in
more and more taxpayers money it becomes
politically impossible to deny demands
for greater resources and in the end it
squeezes to the very fringes any private
alternatives so that you end up in a
situation like in Britain where there is
private insurance for the very very
wealthy for a tiny number of people who
can afford to buy their way out of the
NHS even though they've already
obviously paid for it in their in their
taxes but it's such a tiny market that
there isn't really proper any any proper
competition within it and and therefore
90 plus percent of the population are
left dependent on a a state system which
you know contains good people and where
you can sometimes have good experiences
because there are kindly and dedicated
doctors and nurses in it but where
overall it is not nearly as good a
system as it would be if we had the kind
of consumer choice the opportunity for
address that you have in your system
David Cameron it is polling numbers now
or I mean overwhelmingly favoring the
Tories for the first time in a very long
time what do you think that the American
right can learn from David Cameron he is
sort of lunged towards the center in a
lot of ways what it what is well how are
these new Tories in your estimation any
as there any vestige of sort of
Thatcherism left in his people and is
there something that we as Americans or
the American right which is floundering
right now against Barack Obama can learn
from David Cameron I think there are
things the American right can learn it's
a gross oversimplification to say that
he has lunged towards the center in some
ways he has been much more radical than
any previous Conservative leader
including Margaret Thatcher not least on
this agenda of democratization and
decentralization of power he's gone
further on those things elected sheriffs
and local sales tax and so on than any
any previous
leader what would you learn I'd say this
look if you're a conservative it is very
easy to be negative because the world is
not the way we would like it heaven
knows that there are lots of things to
complain about and we complain you know
and in a way we're right to complain but
we we come across very easily as
curmudgeonly if all we do is complain
and the lesson you could take it from
from Cameron or you could take it from
Regan in a domestic context is that to
be a successful conservative you also
have to imbue your vision with a little
breath of warmth you have to convey a
sense of optimism that you don't just
criticize what's wrong although heaven
knows there is plenty to criticize you
also posit a vision of what could be
better you give the voters a sense that
there is a better tomorrow and that if
they vote for you there will be tangible
and immediate consequences that will
improve their lives and if you can do
that rather than being the angry old man
I find myself doing at some times you
know I was doing it when the Prime
Minister came to Brussels if you could
do that then people come with you Daniel
hem
thank you for him thank you very much
Michael Moynihan with recent TV and
thank you for watching